- Is this banned in Europe?
This is the kinda thing
that isn't allowed in Europe
but makes it to America.
That's the kind of things this is.
- (laughs) Everything.
(club music)
- Today we're gonna be
trying the new Starbucks
crystal ball Frappucino.
- Maybe it'll be shiny.
- Yeah.
- Or shimmery.
- Maybe have some vanilla in there.
- I'm thinking more like
blueberry chocolate.
- I'm also wondering if
there's maybe gonna be
a really cool color gradient.
- It's definitely gonna be cute.
- Definitely.
It's gonna be Instagram-able.
- It's so cute.
- What is this?
(both gasp in surprise)
- What?
- It's green at the bottom.
Is it mint?
- I want to take a picture of
it before I mix it together.
- Do you want this one in it too?
- Oh yeah, let's do both
'cause they're different.
Portrait mode obviously.
- Oh, they're sugar crystals.
- Whoah.
- They're like crystals.
- This matches my outfit.
- Oh there is a color gradient.
Yeah, okay.
- There is, see?
- Can we take selfies with this?
Is that okay?
Does that mess up the video?
Oh we're cute.
Come closer.
- Okay.
- It's thick.
Yours has some yellow, in there.
- Or do we sip from the top to the bottom?
- I'm gonna go from the
bottom and see what happens.
- Yeah, let's try.
- It tastes fruity.
- Oh wow.
- Pure sugar, just like I thought.
- The more I drink it, I feel
like it's making me magical.
- There's like a fruity,
it's like fruity milk.
- I wonder if I mix it a
little bit if it changes.
- Yeah it's a little strong at the bottom.
- I feel like a child eating Pixy Stix.
- There's like a peaches and cream flavor
to the whole thing.
I actually really like this.
- I feel like this is less
of a magic crystal ball
and more of a tropical
seahorse fruituccino.
- It's a sassy, sassy,
sugar-fest in my mouth
and I'm not complaining.
- I probably would InstaStory this
because it's very weird looking.
- Overall, I think the drink is good.
Would I get it again?
(noncommittal vocalization)
- It has a quality about it.
It just makes you wanna go back for more.
- I only buy Frappucinos
when I'm sad, so it's fine.
But I would buy this if I needed it.
- I do enjoy things that sort of, like,
spice up the day, you know?
This is a fun Thursday
because of this drink.
- A little bit of magic.
- We're just two girls hanging out,
drinking fraps, being magical.
- And my lipstick stayed on.
- Wow, yeah.
- I know, girl.